we have this tweet from Betty Johnson
Elon Musk calls the suppression of the
hunter Biden laptop story election
interference quote some of these
conspiracy theories have turned out to
be true I want to play this clip for you
I just want to stress this one point as
we're talking about the Durham report
and the interference in our election and
Trump's presidency from 2016 until 2020
we also get to talk about the second
election interference of intelligence
agencies when they sought to suppress
and did suppress the hunter Biden laptop
story here is Elon Musk giving an
interview on the matter patient of this
I mean
um you know you do some tweets that seem
to be or at least give support to some
who would call others conspiracy
theories
well yes but I mean honestly you know
so many conspiracy theories uh have
turned out to be true
which ones well like the hunter Biden
laptop that's true yeah yeah so yeah uh
you know that that that was a pretty big
deal there was Twitter and and and
others engaged in active suppression of
information that was relevant to the
public
um that's that's a that's a terrible
thing that happened that's like an
interference and not uh and also what
wasn't mentioned about Elon was that the
intelligence agency signed off on this
letter which was then weaponized by
people in the media who willfully lie to
manipulate this is once again a very
similar story of election interference
from intelligence agencies Democrats and
the media there is no country unless
these people are criminally charged
arrested and removed from polite Society
because they're criminals who engage in
criminal activity but if you consider
that it's just an accident in their sawi
oh they're sorry
now I feel bad Shameless I mean it was
let him go it was a mistake you know
that's why Penn State I feel like
they're not sorry they're just like we
did some stuff wrong and we change our
own rules so we won't com we won't do
anything wrong again but we don't know
that they've changed the rules to per
now they've changed the rules to permit
them to act the way they did you know
they've just legalized their actions
probably and I love this rationalization
that you get from the left where they'll
say okay like we yes we were vehemently
wrong about this every step of the way
and we did try to ruin people's lives
and we did misinform the American people
but like we didn't mean to yeah we saw
yeah exactly we saw during the pandemic
we saw it during Russia gate we see this
with the left all of the time it's like
okay well if you're wrong about
everything all the time I kind of don't
care if you were lying or not I know
that I can't trust you ever they're just
sorry you figured it out they're not
sorry they didn't exactly and this is
how it works you never admit you're
wrong you move on to the next scam
that's how scammers work right a scammer
doesn't go like okay so like
wasn't really a Nigerian prince but I am
trying to call you about your car's
extended warranty so they just move from
the Nigerian prince thing to your car's
extended rewards without ever talking to
you about the car admitting that you
they were wrong yeah it's like you're
not a Nigerian prince click yeah fun
Rings again I'd like to talk to you
about your car's extended warranty
really to go well I feel like we should
just start our stop watches and see what
big Revelations gonna come out to
distract us from this because that's I
feel like how you can tell time in
America well more importantly I wonder
what the next big election interference
is going to be in 2024 well what lie
will they push next well and this is
this is what's so wild right so over 10
percent of Biden voters according to
surveys not only did not know that the
hunter Biden laps top story was uh a
thing because of how suppressed it was
they said if they had known about it
they would not have voted for Joe Biden
okay the idea that 10 of Biden voters
surveyed if that really does apply to
the rest of the voice the population
would not have swayed the election
what's your what's your Source uh
Washington examiner there was a poll
that they published right after these I
want to make sure we have the number
correct yeah yeah I I actually think it
might have been more than ten percent
more than pull this up I remember
Rasmussen had one that was like six or
seven percent okay either way either way
it's a substantial amount it's enough
people to theoretically swing the
election depending on where they're
they're centered or where they're based
now that's all evil that is evil that is
clear corporate interference in American
elections and I would say that that's
actually more heinous than uh
non-government actors in Russia spending
forty six thousand dollars on Facebook
ads not all of which were from one
single partisan perspective on top of
that we had actual elected leaders
referring to that as an act of War an
act of War so what do we call it when
American corporations do the exact same
thing on a much larger scale which
there's actually good polling data to
indicate did sway the election well and
they're doing it on a much larger 100
multi-hundred million dollar almost
billion dollar scale when it comes to
groups like the center for Tech and
Civic life getting money from the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative when you talk
about the lie that they're going to
Peddle I think Universal mail and voting
I'm sure there'll be some sort of Public
Health Emergency that necessitates
rolling that up but it's interesting I
put a story up today so obviously the
center for for Tech and Civic life the
Zuckerberg funded election group they
had to sort of Rebrand since they came
under a bunch of scrutiny during the
2020 election but one of their their new
groups it's called The Alliance for
election Excellence it's a very good
name but they're now giving they have an
80 million dollar War chest and they're
now giving a half a million dollar
grants to local election offices across
the country and they're buying them
catch this office space to store mail-in
ballots and to also store election
tabulation machines so they're up to
their old price of them so I know I'm
sure very altruistic anything Mark
Zuckerberg does is marked by by altruism
and if it's not altruistic it was an
accident
election side because like yeah me and
my wife like peace out we're done but no
they just use another Shady nonsense
you're giving it to someone to give to
them you remember when he he was like
legal Health Alliance in covid
Zuckerberg reportedly gave all his money
away or something like that what but it
turned out he put it in an LLC to avoid
the death tax and the inheritance tax
something like that happened I could be
wrong but they were like wow
Zuckerberg's giving away all his money
and they were like yeah to a company so
that when he dies it doesn't get taxed
at 50 yeah it was like the Patagonia
thing their founder was like we're gonna
give all of our money away and it's like
oh actually they get a huge tax credit
for doing this they're not just they're
not here to save the planet they're here
to help themselves and the sad thing is
if he said it he was doing it to avoid
taxes it would be way cooler right like
I might actually appreciate that if he's
gonna lie about giving it to the poor
okay well you're a slimy guy you're
lying about giving money to the poor if
he was just honest about it look this
horrible government that does horrible
things and is going to spend this money
on nonsense isn't going to get a penny
of it I go ah yeah I get it I understand
they they all do this these wealthy
individuals will be like I'm gonna
donate 99 of my money and then like
you'll get a guy named you know Seamus
Coughlin who's a billionaire yeah and
he'll be like I'm gonna donate 999
million dollars to charity and then
he'll start a charity called the shaman
Sheamus Coughlin foundation and I'll
donate it to himself exactly that way he
can write off all of the income and then
have it as a non-profit and then keep
the money a full fun fact there are
actually studies that show inheritance
taxes increase income inequality because
the lower classes inherit a larger
percentage of their net worth than the
upper class does and so usually what
inheritance taxes actually do is just
completely screw Farmers over because a
person has a farm that they spent their
entire life working on and yeah like the
farm and the farming equipment are
rather expensive but a lot of these
people are just making a normal middle
class living and then they have to pay
this insane inheritance tax before they
can pass it on to their children so they
end up having a to sell their their land
off yeah that's why a lot of firms go
into trust right they do it to avoid
having to go through the process or
llc's like trusts clever ways they they
uh avoid paying taxes but for those who
can't avoid it or for those who don't
know better than to avoid it or even
people you know outside of the context
of farming who just have a house and
they don't know how to leave it to their
their kids without avoiding the taxes
they end up getting screwed Millionaires
and billionaires are going to find their
way around any set of taxes right just
like Zuckerberg did but poor people are
not buying things as a rich person is
not the same as buying things as a poor
person nope if you're a poor person who
needs a car you save up 10 you go to the
car dealership you say I want this you
know twenty thousand dollar car they say
okay it's two thousand dollars down and
then you take out a loan for the other
18 and then you got to pay a certain
percentage on it so you are losing money
on your asset by the time you finally
get that asset you've ended up paying
double for it so you've lost tens of
thousands if you're rich you walk in
write a check boom you have the car the
car's value effectively stays the same
let's use a better example like land or
property yeah if you're poor and you're
buying a house you get a loan you pay
interest you lose money to the banks to
acquire this after 30 years or whatever
you finally pay it off you're like I did
it I paid off my house and you've lost
twice the value of the house in the
purchase so basically you only retain
half of the value of your of your own
money you're rich and you got cash snap
your fingers you buy it you retain all
of the value not the same thing and then
they do these tricks where you know they
can give the money to their own kids
well and who gets the value the rich the
banks yep the Federal Reserve I guess
but I guess this isn't supposed to be
Occupy Wall Street cast we are talking
about elections don't complain about but
hey you know uh Steve talks about the
stuff all the time I'm gonna say yeah he
wants to tax all these people I don't
agree with these well-tech stuff but
Steve's he's adamant on we don't have to
because they're not they're good they're
going to use the money to fund all of
these groups like election rigging
groups whatever you want to call them
and I've always supported that was one
of the first policies that Steve had put
back when I was in high school watching
him speak I think at the Oxford Union
and I was like this is so right and
what's so funny is you know put aside I
always love talking to to Uber drivers
Democrat Republican and like that's the
one issue that they can always get
behind is that taxing the rich but
actually taxing them substantively and
meaningfully and making the policy so
it's not just that the hyper-connected
rich uh get they don't have to pay for
sure but it's everyone but then the
government gets the money and gives it
to the FBI yeah exactly so therein lies
the problem you have to defund the FBI
well yeah that's my concerned I think
sex trafficking operation but the rest
of the FBI yes yeah well like with the
FBI with all these institutions and it's
not even just the Deep States the
government overall as Tim alluded to it
it's all incredibly corrupt they spend
our money horribly I understand what
you're saying well taxes made me nervous
for a number of reasons I think you know
in principle my main belief I would say
economically is is in property ownership
and I don't just mean that in like a
strictly laissez-faire sense I think the
more people who own property the better
we offer the better off we are as a
country I think it gives everyone a
stake in the future you know a country
of property owners is obviously better
than a country of renters I'm a very big
believer in the middle class and lower
class being able to own property and I
think a lot has to be done in order to
make that a realistic possibility for
people in the future but
with wealth taxes I mean
the issue is with unrealized capital
gains you're you're taxing something
that doesn't actually exist yet so then
someone has to sell off a portion of
their company and if it was just people
who were Ultra Ultra ultra wealthy I
could sort of understand but that always
trickles down right anytime the
government says we're only going to tax
people above a certain limit they end up
lowering that bar until eventually you
were all paying that way the initial
income tax was like three percent and it
was only for the ultra wealthy and now
here we are with poor people paying 20
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time